You're grounded.
Sorry. What?
Terrestrial missions only.
Whose protocol is this?
Your mother's.
Welcome back,
everyone. It's Charlie Marvel.
Just released a first
look at the Marvels movie.
We already know
some of what's going on in the movie.
What's going on with the villains?
How it connects with Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're new to the channel,
we're still doing a giveaway for Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania IMAX tickets.
All you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and post all your predictions
for how you want all the Marvel's
characters to fit into Qing Dynasty.
Pretty much anybody
who's ever been in a marvel
movie is going to be somewhere
in Kang Dynasty in Avengers
six Secret Wars in that also includes
all the Fox Marvel movies.
In all the other connected Marvel movies.
It's Sony, like the Spider-Man movies,
Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield, everybody.
Because Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania just came out.
I won't include spoilers for that movie,
but some of the stuff from the trailer
does connect with references and artifacts
we know
are going to be in the Marvel movie.
So I will talk about that stuff, but
I don't really consider that a spoiler.
This is what the characters
are going to look like.
Marvel released this
an announce that the movie
is going to be released in November,
pushing it a couple of months.
Originally was going to be July.
This is just the main three.
We already know
about some of the villains,
but Monica Rambeau, for instance,
will wear this suit.
She's going to be going by her photon
name from the comics.
According to the writers.
You can see
she's got an upgraded, more comic book
accurate version of her
white and black suit.
She's still going to be working for Sword
at the beginning of the movie
for Nick Fury on his sword space station.
They're calling it the peak.
They're just what they call
the actual space station in the comics.
That's basically what they teased
in the Wandavision
Post-Credits scene for her character,
where the Skrulls came to take her to Nick
Fury on the space station.
If it wasn't clear what's going on
with the actual space station,
because they haven't
really talked about that,
they don't really get into it
too much during Wandavision either.
They just teased it
briefly at the end of the series.
It's meant to be a vastly upgraded version
of Marvel's spaceship
from the nineties that had been left
hidden in Earth's orbit.
Just cloak from sensors.
Nick Fury in the good scrolls,
not the bad ones
that we're going to see
during Secret Invasion,
which is meant to take place
before the events of the Marvel's movie,
He and TALOS, the good Skrulls
built a bigger space station,
starting with Marvel's
original space station, her ship.
We only saw a small portion of it
in the Spider-Man far from home
Post-Credits scene.
It seems like an eon ago that we saw
that it's been 84 years
since we saw that space station,
and he's been working with the scrolls
since the nineties to construct it
as a means of defense
in case the Kree ever returned in force
like they threatened
at the end of the first Captain
Marvel movie
like you would expect Sword
to do from the comics.
They're meant to defend Earth from space
based threats, whereas Shield is worried
more about terrestrial threats
from planet Earth
just to address everything
that happened in one division with sword
going off the rails with Tyler Hayward,
It sounds like everything he did trying
to reactivate Vision, gaslighting
Scarlet Witch, messing with her powers.
That was him going
rogue against Nick Fury is orders.
Since Nick Fury is still technically
running the show from the space station,
if you couldn't tell Zoom and enhance,
Captain Marvel
is wearing the exact same suit
she was wearing in the Miss Marvel
Post-Credits scene.
But Kamala Khan has a totally new suit.
This one is a little bit
shinier, has way more red in it,
but it's the same basic design language
as her previous suit.
Like it's a shinier,
nicer version of her previous suit
because her last suit
was meant to be homemade.
It was kind of like Spider-Man
is first suit totally homemade.
Speaking of Spider-Man, Kevin Biggie said
that her vibe in the movie is a bit
like Spider-Man during Captain America
Civil War, like the new young Buck
who's there to help out
but isn't quite sure of their powers yet.
They also confirmed that our Ms..
Marvel post-credits scene
theories were true.
What happened here is that Ms..
Marvel's bangle gives her
the ability to switch places with people,
and she literally just swapped places
in the universe with Captain Marvel.
So what's happening here
is that actual Carol Danvers?
Captain Marvel is standing in
Kamala Khan's bedroom, confused.
She's about to go downstairs,
and there are going to be
some very confused parents.
And a second, too, before she tries to fly
back to Chris Grohl Space,
where Kamala Khan is now,
also just as confused as to
why she's on an alien planet
all of a sudden.
Monica Rambeau
was meant to start the movie,
still working on the sword space station.
She's just been working there
ever since the end of Wandavision, trying
to figure out how her photon powers work
and going on missions for Nick Fury.
They're changing her
a little bit from the comics
just to make sure she doesn't get to Opie.
Her powers are basically the ability
to absorb and redirect any kind of energy.
There was another time in the comics where
she also was able to become pure energy.
So that just gives you an idea
for how her power scale,
I think could just keep getting more
and more powerful
the more she understands how
whatever energy she's working with works.
There's a couple of qualifiers
that the comics have to keep her
from getting too powerful.
But there are a couple of times
in the comics where she has gotten
super powerful, for instance,
because she can absorb any kind of energy.
She could theoretically absorb
infinite stone energy and redirected.
The problem is that in order to do that,
she'd have to understand
how the energy works in Infinity Stone.
Energy is just so complex
that almost nobody understand it,
which is how they keep her from becoming
like the most powerful character
in the entire universe.
The whole thing
with the Bangles in the movie
is that they're going to explain
what happened to the second Bangle.
Remember during Ms..
Marvel,
they explained there were supposed to be
two kamala's great grandmothers race.
The Jinn spoke about two
in that ten rings temple.
There were so many theories
about this and connections to Shang.
She's ten rings of power
because they're worn kind of like bangles
around their arms.
But during the Marvel's movie,
the main villain is supposed to be Darb
Ben, who's a character from the comics
who's just meant to be one of the leaders
of the Empire, I think is part of this
whole idea that to create Captain Marvel,
they're supposed to explain.
They believe
that she killed the Supreme Intelligence
and there is no supreme intelligence
during the events of the movie.
It just da been leading their people,
orchestrating this plot.
She's played by Zoe Ashton, who's actually
married to Tom Hiddleston in real life.
So small Loki series connection there.
She's going to be using the second bangle
during the movie and needs
both of them to power a weapon
she's using.
So she's trying to take Kamala
Khan's bangle to get the other.
Would you think is meant to solve
confirmed the theory
that the bands are actually based
on the Kree Naga bands from the comics
which were kind of like Green Lantern
rings.
They turn thought into energy
and you can create constructs with them,
which kind of explains the way Ms..
Marvel creates constructs.
She's also meant to be a mutant,
so she has powers on top of that.
That's like a whole separate thing,
though.
Her being a mutant has nothing to do
with the powers of the Bangles.
And just like you see the swapping
in the Ms..
Marvel Post-Credits scene
during the movie,
that's going to be a big thing
where Captain Marvel, Monica Rambeau,
Kamala Khan are trying to stop Da
Bend the Kree from using their weapon
in Kamala's powers and her being
keep causing the three of them
to constantly switch places.
And it just causes a bunch of chaos
for the three of them
until they figure it out
and use it to win their boss fights.
They will explain why
Monica Rambeau had such a beef
with Captain Marvel during Wandavision
and it's pretty much a confirmation
of all of our theories at the time.
It's mostly because Monica believes
that she never returned to see her mother
while her mother was dying of cancer.
Remember Monica Rambeau got snap,
so she missed her mother's death.
Her mother did not get snapped and she's
supposed to be Carol Danvers, best friend,
I believe, during the movie.
They will explain.
The Captain Marvel
did actually come to visit Maria Rambeau
while she was dying, though.
Remember the 838 universe version
that we saw who became a version
of Captain Marvel is actually meant
to be an Easter egg for the comics.
When Monica Rambeau actually became
the first female Captain Marvel.
The whole idea in the comics
is that for the longest time,
for a very long time,
Carol Danvers was called Ms..
Marvel.
And it wasn't until
the last like ten, 15 years or so that she
started calling herself Captain Marvel.
Monica Rambeau started going by the name
Captain Marvel back in 1982 in an Amazing
Spider-Man issue, of all places,
the real big Angelus Easter Egg.
Is it?
The Kree have been referring
to Captain Marvel as The Annihilator
Island is like one of the biggest space
based villains
that Marvel hasn't done yet, who people
mostly remember from the Annihilation.
That was a huge Infinity War level
crossover event where everyone fought
a nihilist.
He's meant to be a villain
from the Negative zone,
which is an anti-matter universe
that they featured in the 2015 Fantastic
Four movie A Nihilist is a character
from the Fantastic Four comics.
I think them using the Annihilator
title in the movie is their way of teasing
that they'll eventually do a nihilist,
either in Marvel's
Phase six or After Secret Wars.
At some point.
I believe the person who wrote that last
Fantastic Four movie
where they went to the negative zone
said that they actually
were going to do a nihilist
during the movie
and a version of Galactus,
but the whole movie wound up
getting changed,
like they changed
the entire end of the film.
What it could have
should they're rebooting everything now
so it doesn't matter.
Matt Shakman,
who directed on one division,
is actually going
to be directing the Fantastic Four movie.
We'll probably find out who's
going to be playing some of the characters
before the end of the year
because they actually start shooting it
early next year around this time.
The other big connection
between the Marvel's movie and Avengers
Qing Dynasty are the incursions
and the time runs out storyline.
They're supposed to have
an actual incursion during the movie,
like finally show us an incursion.
What's happening on screen.
We've only heard characters
talk about it up to this point,
like Reed Richards of the Fantastic
Four in the A3 Universe
or CLEA at the end of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
Basically what happens during an incursion
is because you're talking about parallel
universes, different versions of Planet
Earth, for instance,
just coexist within a similar space
and start to collide with each other.
And it happens, for all matter,
in both universes.
So like planets,
suns, everything colliding with each other
until they destroy each other.
During Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania,
when Kang is explaining incursions
to Janet Van Dyne,
his animated 3D model of the multiverse
timelines shows a bunch of them
popping basically in overlapping this.
I'm showing you
what it looks like when incursion happens
from outside the timelines.
It'd be like watching incursions
from the TVA during the Marvel movies.
We'll watch a version of that happen,
and I believe
Monica Rambeau is going to help them
stop it from happening.
Using her powers like the whole idea is
that another universe is about to destroy
the main 616 Marvel universe
and she helps to stop it, but gets trapped
in whatever
that other universe winds up being.
They didn't say what it's going to be.
Hopefully she gets stuck in like Tobey
Maguire Spider-Man universe or Andrew
Garfield's universe.
You could just see her looking for
help. Hello, Peter.
Number two. Peter. Number three.
Are you out there?
Are you available to help us do
more videos for the movie?
When we get more footage,
we learn more details.
I think we're going
to get the first trailer.
When Guardians of the Galaxy
three hits theaters,
I'm still finishing a giant Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania Full Breakdown
and Easter Eggs for the entire movie
that'll post on Saturday.
Make sure you enable alerts
from my channel
so you don't miss that and see the movie.
If you haven't seen it yet.
Everyone click here for my Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania Post-Credits
Scenes video.
There are two of them
in Click here for my new Flash trailer
with so many Batman Easter eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.